here's what would happen if you stopped  brushing your teeth  after a week you'd start to notice some  serious bad breath  not long after that the plaque on your  teeth would begin to harden and form  tartar this is like a really hard plaque  that discolors your teeth at this point  only a dentist would be able to get rid  of it and on top of all this your tooth  enamel would begin to get damaged  after one month you'd start to get  cavities in your teeth and they'd  eventually fill with pus  you'd also start to develop gingivitis  which would inflame the gums around your  teeth  good luck trying to eat anything at this  point  after a year the inner layer of your  gums would start to pull away from your  teeth and form pockets which would  collect food and bacteria  then your immune system would start to  destroy your gums and your teeth would  start to fall out of your mouth one by  one so